listen I'm on drowsy Benadryl right now
okay that's my excuse what happened to
the seahorse too hard
wow-whee she tried I'm super-pumped guys
finished the first draft hustle while
you wait
so I'm talking about
[Music]
good morning everybody happy day five
lena slept in a lot no Emma slept didn't
a lot we got up at eleven and we're
getting ready for the day everything is
closed for food because we miss
breakfast so we're gonna get ready for
lunch
and we would they'd see today so I was
planning on working on my youtube
channel watching the videos for you guys
but they blocked YouTube on the boat so
not sure what I'm gonna do maybe just
hand it over to my team trust them to
deliver the gold and I spend the time
today
working on my new book it could be fun
we'll see
[Music]
all right had a good meal
how you feeling Mina it's feeling good
I'm getting allergies never gotten
allergies on a cruise ship before but
the North Sea doesn't have a lot of
salts usually the salt water gets rid of
everything but North Sea doesn't have a
lot of salts which I didn't know so
we're gonna head to the medical office
and get some allergy medication Nina
insisted that it happens you thanked me
after I get stubborn about some things
sometimes most of the time but Nina's
very stubborn too no you're very
stubborn in your answer there Nina so
we're gonna go find that I hope they
have allergy medication so that eopns
can have a good rest of the trip all
right medical hours are only 8 to 9:30
a.m. and 6 to 7:30 p.m.
that's some pretty quality working hours
for a doctor huh for that you get to
work what three hours a day we decided
to go for a walk outside
one the work out the food and to some of
the still some salt in the water
so hopefully that kicks in for me
fingers crossed
[Music]
I was about to make a video while Nina
wasn't looking I snuck I got some mango
cobbler with caramel sauce
and then I put some ice cream on top of
it okay that's what you married
alright we're sitting here on the pool
deck I'm gonna enjoy my peach cobbler
with ice cream get some work a little
bit done for the channel I can't get
access to YouTube so there's only a
limited amount I can do all on the film
in a couple videos I think though and
then I get to work in a new book yeah
pretty pumped
meanwhile Nina is looking at the drink
menu then it's gonna go get some Sudoku
and relax and enjoy the music and work
on her new book or work on her new
YouTube channel has lots of people are
subscribing to it when's the next video
for your channel Nina she wants her
drink don't talk to me until she has a
drink
okay we'll see you soon
painkiller the stink of the day what is
the painkiller where's that the
painkiller rum pineapple or other wine
why not we'll do two to painkillers
all right all right so these are all my
remaining notes for the new book
this page is a page of the notes that I
need to translate into that to make it
available for you guys
[Music]
Dinah's back what did you get
holy cow OSHA's salad
and a piece of fish or chicken and soup
and our drinks arrived our drinks
arrived the painkiller give it a try
baby and see if it takes away your pain
you need to take pictures of all her
food first the camera eats first Wow
[Music]
leave this back how am I gonna do
laundry in the sink nina budd tied she
bought me some benadryl we love Nina
she's special
she tell me why she got us angry well I
got her a sangria hello how's the
sangria every drink is strong here and
I'm working on the book making good
progress pretty pumped alright it's made
some good progress on the book got about
70% done what I wanted to for today so
maybe we'll spend a little time later
Nina got upset at me for not drinking in
the water
that's the hydrated kind of fix his
allergies she gave me some claritin -
she went first to get benadryl then we
realized that benadryl is drowsy and
then I just had to get some clarity as
well so lots of love from the wife we
love you Nina thank you for always
thinking about us Nina and by us I mean
me
special Christine we should put like
hearts over Christina's head Christina's
name
I mean over Nina's head Christina let's
put hearts I listen I'm on drowsy
benadryl right now okay that's my excuse
all right so you know suggested that I
go back to the cabin and I have a nap
maybe I always feel better then I had a
nap I feel a little bit better
good job mean it we are heading off to
the teppanyaki dinner reservation this
is the most popular restaurant on the
boat you have to make reservations for
it so we did it's a steak house I think
we're gonna go see ready to eat
we're hungry this is a menu on the back
of course origami
Selina's gonna try let's see your
origami seahorse Tina what happened to
the seahorse Tina too hard
well please she tried better than my
seahorse that's what my sealer says like
it's a cool idea to have it on the menu
step one is too difficult to do okay
Nina decided to make something else
let's show show the show believe nation
what you made Mina the crane good job
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how's the Stinkmeaner you know like me
that proof alright just finish the
dinner what did you take I'm full I had
to eat
Nina's cake dessert let a big kick
person but that was some yummy green tea
next what are we doing you're gonna go
where head
next relax the theme is gonna go work
out I'm taking a pass because of the
allergies
hopefully these pills will kick in soon
and then maybe won't lead us out I'll
keep working on my book yeah
hustle while you wait so I'm talking
about
[Music]
hello police nation finish my dinner
have a glass of wine after dinner and
I'm off to work out right now have fun
Nina we'll see you love you
all right Nina's gone time to work on
the book I'm super-pumped guys finished
the first draft at least the chunk that
I wanted to get done today I'm not
showing you everything here but this is
your cheat sheet for success I took the
top 500 rules from my channel I could
dance it down to the ten most common
themes that keep coming up and that's
what this book is about so pumped for
you guys to see this I'm excited
the wife has returned how is he workout
one hour high five for the one hour I
got everything I wanted to do in the
book and more today nothing for me no
actually I was I don't know if you want
anything so I just got them but you well
last time I eat the pizza you gotta cut
that ate all of it cuz I got four slices
you got okay
I know oh wow nice how much love is
there for the Nina so special okay
that's good you deserve it all right
maybe I'll go up and get some ice cream
too
all right we just came back from
upstairs you should be you should be on
the on this side and the inside look at
Nina there she is
sadly get some celebratory ice cream
sundae and we got a lemon meringue pie
and Nina got some more pizza and ice
cream and another glass of wine
which is somewhere so we're gonna enjoy
and celebrate our first day at sea
pretty productive day
all in all looking forward to hitting up
Oslo tomorrow thank you guys so much for
watching we believe in you we hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever yours is much loved laughs see
you soon bye